well guys that is a wrap for 2019 and as
far as eSports goes it was an incredible
year and we've got a top-10 dedicated to
the best of the best from that year but
that ain't why we're here today today
we're here to ease off on the dramatic
music just a little bit to forget about
being reversed cymbals sound effects and
for once not talk about the Olaf boost
today we're counting down the top 10
fails of 2019 oh and before you go we
realize that everybody makes mistakes
and we're poking fun at these guys
because we love them so keep that right
starting us off at number 10 is g2
eSports making an unforgivable mistake
at the starladder berlin major how they
done that
a sneaky bomb plant from the straw
should have caught g2 on the backfoot
but a 3k from shocks and a great defense
from the rest of the squad all but
secured the round win that is if they
have remembered to defuse the ball you
have someone looking hot you have device
alert a low rambling wait
geez gentlemen the kid what are they
doing set up funny the bomb nope no
one's done that
so it was one little mistake what could
that cost them well with the straws at
15 rounds just the entire map coming in
at number nine is uke at the cod world
League Championship I know what you guys
are thinking call of duty at number nine
well here Mia going into the tournament
splice was touted as a top team and
after an undefeated group stage
everybody expected them to make a deep
run but a stumble against eg in the
winner's bracket sent them down to
losers where they faced off against the
amateur team war squad in this do-or-die
match war put up a real fight taking
them to the full five maps and then
during game point to the final map or
he's trying to get away deep fry keeps
on running away
the eight spot on our list goes to tweak
at Evo 2019
no we're not talking about his grand
finals all credit to M Kao for that one
we're talking about his winners final
set against gluttony in which tweek was
rolling on Ivysaur with the downer spike
as well look at me pointing trouble
landing and now ya down there through
the platform in the off air bread and
water pokemon trainer saw up to Oh in
the set with both players on their final
stock tweek was setting himself up to
land that final blow and punch his
ticket to those grand finals when the
time came tweek miss pressed he
accidentally switched out his IV store
for Charizard and gave gluttony the
split-second opportunity he needed to
win the next match and bring the set
back to even standing at 2-2 in other
words this one error almost cost week is
blindly swinging his way to our seventh
spot is Jamie and his knife with at IEM
katowice Mitch to drop as well it's a
two-on-two Nate it's gonna land on top
of the ball it's a smoke Jamie AWP
switches to the knife it's all he has to
work with they're on it they tap it they
want to bait him out he's swinging
Dean to seven and a Pagar goes down but
insert through with ends at fifteen
rounds a vanguard needed to win every
single round from there on out just to
keep their tournament hopes on life
support but one cheeky smoke from Ariel
and a frankly incredible miss play from
Jame made it easy friends [ __ ] to drop
as well it's a two-on-two Nate it's
gonna land on top of the ball it's a
smoke Jamie AWP switches to the knife
it's all he has to work with they're all
right they tap it they want to bait him
out he's swinging the word cringe is a
mainstay of the eSports lexicon and
there's nothing better than an interview
that delivers us that sweet sweet
uncomfortable measure that's why at
number six we have golden boys interview
with Fabian at the Raleigh major you so
much gentlemen here's Pangu wave g2
esports ladies jump hike what did I do
wrong
well the obvious you don't know me done
because baby and baby and oh my god I'm
so sorry I'm so sorry
kicking off an interview with a member
of g2 golden boy got a little confused
about who he was actually interviewing
this is my first time here folks so you
know you gotta give me a little give me
a little slack
gave me a little slack but hey guys
everybody makes mistakes and we all know
how difficult it is to perform live on a
grand stage like that I think we can all
cut Matt Andrews oh [ __ ] I mean golden
boy some slack on this one fair enough
fair enough
and I like this guy I like this guy
first time and I'm I'm diggin it coming
in at number five are the ridiculous
game crashes during the Rainbow six
siege rally major unit getting the plant
down while cameraman watches Shepard
that's the connector player as I said
and the evil eye will zap away but it's
not doing any damage no damage or is it
frozen what is going on oh it's weave
yeah we've crashed during a round where
phase had a 3-man advantage the game
experienced the first of two incredibly
unfortunate crashes barring a miracle
that round would have gone to face but
the tournament admins ruled in favor of
a round reset stealing away the round
from the Brazilians it doesn't matter
what decisions coming out there's gonna
be unhappy fans happy players and the
sons made so you you have to roll with
it at this point that round ruling would
have been a huge point of contention if
the game had not crashed a game a couple
of rounds later no way not again now
it's empires turn to be upset this time
it rubbed Empire of around ish talk
about game balance perfectly balanced
c9s are infamous in overwatch it's a
mistake that just shouldn't happen at
the pro level that's why it number four
we have the Shang nine the worst c9 in
overwatch history and overtime defenses
although you're just never gonna be
efficient but the EMP is gonna look to
shut down luffy does have that transcend
it's ready to go
EMP gonna come out
we'll have to get a replay on that yeah
since the game was in overtime the
Dragons needed a member on the payload
at all times even while at the
checkpoint
unfortunately young Jin forgot about all
that and this happened there was nothing
else going on the International is where
dota sports lives and dies and that's
why when a team makes a tournament
ending misclick it is a big [ __ ] deal
the number three fail on our list is
alliances gyrocopter miss click at TI 9
that is true something that we
definitely did not expect right after
the group stage Alliance found
themselves in the first round of the
lower bracket facing off against RNG in
a single elimination match a notorious
round of TI known for its upsets both
teams knew there was no room for error
so when encinia clicked the ban gyro but
picked it for his team instead
everyone's heart sank while the pic
didn't lose in the game entirely
it absolutely threw Alliance off their
game and its impact cannot be
understated
well then I'd be oh those a gyro bun um
a runner up fail of 2019 is simple
playing on a knife's edge versus Team
Liquid at ESL one cologne at fifteen
rounds and holding the advantage in a
3v1 this map between not a sponsor and
team liquid was in the books for Navi or
at least it should have been to be
confirmed nearly got knife simple of
course trying to push it through see
simple had the jump on team liquids lone
remaining member nitro and could have
had the entire game right there and then
but he stayed true to himself and went
for that cheeky knife which cost him
dearly
nitro went on to clutch and Team Liquid
mounted to come back off of that round
going on to force overtime win the map
and win the entire series nights they
had the game in the palm of their hand
man they threw in the trash simple in a
three-on-one go for that knife attempt
at map point has cost him their map pick
and a best of three against number one
in the world coming in at number one on
our list is Ben's positioning error
during the spring finals of the LCS the
series that pitted two of anaise
greatest franchises head-to-head saw
Team Liquid attempting to complete the
reverse sweep on TSM who had the lead in
the final game with no team in sight in
Game five Sven wandered too deep into
the river spotted the enemy skarner and
nonchalantly attacked him baffling
analysts and fans alike Stan walks right
into him announces team limits moment
they found their opening team liquid
push that an advantage in to an easy
barren and slowly choked out TSM they
went on to take the series take the
championship and punch their ticket to
msi the question is can they find those
margins can they find that opening so
far TSM has outmaneuvered
what is he totally a parent Stan walks
right into him announces team liquids
moment they found their opening well not
the end of his tenure with TSM the
missplay turned out to be the definitive
highlight or low-light if you like of
spends time on the story franchise that
first pull onto Sven that's what set all
of his back into motion the kill turn
and the three turned into baron turned
in a map control
well guys those are our picks for the
top 10 fails of 2019 you know what to do
next like this video sub to the channel
and comment below and I'll see you next
time man Kyle I cannot believe some of
those fails
especially the g21 even I would remember
to defuse the bomb two hours later oh
yeah I never make mistakes the corner
the hell is wrong with you bro you're
the one that invades all right guys I
get and we good